good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight good night everybody
two days before the Democratic Senate
primary in Pennsylvania back in May
staffers for the John fetterman campaign
announced that their candidate had
tragically suffered a stroke but no
problem in a written statement
purportedly written by John fetterman
himself from the hospital fetterman
announced that he was absolutely fine
I'm feeling much better the statement
read doctors tell me I didn't suffer any
cognitive damage
okay so the primary continued as playing
with fetterman's name on the ballot and
fetterman won he became the Democratic
nominee and that was the last that most
voters heard about John fetterman's
stroke
for months fetterman remained in
semi-seclusion that is the campaign
progressed and the polls tightened he
began to venture out he had no choice
and video clips surfaced at fetterman
speaking at rallies in what seemed to be
a bizarre and highly disjointed way some
began to wonder if he'd really suffered
quote no cognitive damage from his
stroke
it was at this point that fetterman's
personal physician a man called Clifford
Chen who also happened to be a campaign
donor to him and other Democrats rushed
forward to bring science to bear on this
question
in Clifford Chen's considered opinion as
a respected Medical Professional who
works at a major research University
John fetterman was absolutely fine
fetterman was quote recovering well from
his stroke he had quote no work
restrictions and can work full Duty in
public office
in other words John Federman was as
sharp and as healthy as you or me as
anyone in America in fact more so ready
for the Senate
fetterman's wife who presumably would
know seconded this assessment and
attacked anyone who disagreed so did a
group of democratic office holders who
wrote a piece in the Huffington Post
about how their own Strokes had only
enhanced their Public Service a stroke
no big deal it's a good thing actually
ought to be a requisite for service in
the Senate
for their part most of the reporters who
covered John fetterman day-to-day worked
hard to calm concerns about his health
is John fetterman a silver tongued
Wordsmith no they conceded he never has
been but brain damage come on don't be a
bigot that's ableist
until last night that's pretty much
where things stood some people mostly
Republicans thought John Federman might
not be mentally fit to work in the
Senate others mostly Democrats agreed
with Clifford Chen his doctor that
fetterman was absolutely fine so as a
neat partisan split
then fetterman appeared on stage for his
first and only debate and settled this
question for all time John fetterman it
turns out is not capable of driving a
car he should not be allowed to operate
a microwave oven there is no chance that
under any imaginable circumstances John
fetterman could quote serve in the U.S
Senate it's not a close call watch
you're running for a seat that could
decide the balance of power in
Washington what qualifies you to be a
U.S senator you have 60 Seconds
hi good night everybody
what
so that was the moment right at the top
that you know this was not a debate like
the debates you'd seen before most
debates feel pretty scripted in fact
this debate actually was scripted John
Federman had a script he was reading it
but he was still incapable of following
that script
here for example is how fetterman
responded to maybe the most obvious
question of the night one he knew was
coming and of course would have prepared
for here's his answer
you're saying tonight that you support
fracking that you've always supported
fracking but there is that 2018
interview that you said quote I don't
support fracking at all so how do you
square the two
oh I I do support fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking
okay
so a lot of conclusions here the most
obvious why is Clifford Chen still
practicing medicine if you're a
physician are you allowed to lie for
partisan reasons don't we have enough of
that in this country should doctors be
allowed to do that he clearly was lying
that's not a man who can work with no
restrictions in the U.S Senate far from
it and everyone watching every honest
person
would come to that conclusion we could
play you a lot of Clips like that you've
probably seen them already today
but not everyone is an honest person and
to prove it we're going to show you how
MSNBC covered this debate the moment it
ended
here is New York Magazine's Rebecca
trayster
clearly this was a candidate who was
feeling stress and there was such
intense scrutiny often ableist scrutiny
on how he was going to communicate and
he just did a debate in front of you
know the nation you know an audience of
anyone who could listen and it was so
transparent he did fumble he did make
verbal mistakes
um you know and and it was all on view
but the the you know I think it's also
really interesting you played a lot of
Clips there were moments where he was
really strong including that Bernie
Sanders clip including his very fluent
and direct response on raising the
minimum wage I thought was a really
strong moment
so we just keep Clips like that around
Just for future historians to assess
what went wrong in America and we wanted
the
hackiest possible response the most
dishonest assessment ever offered of any
public event and we just played it for
you he was facing ableist scrutiny
because we're literal and can't control
ourselves you just heard her say that
fetterman had a strong answer to a
question talk about patronizing by the
way well we thought we'd go and check
what was his answer you can assess
yourself whether this was quote strong
here it is
what do you say to small business owners
who have told us that if the minimum
wage were increased to 15 an hour it
would put them out of business you have
30 seconds
now we we all have to make sure that
everyone that works is able to that's
that's the most American bargain that if
you work full-time you should be able to
live in dignity as well true and I
believe they haven't have any businesses
being being uh you can't have businesses
being subsidized by not paying
individuals that just simply can't to
pay their own way
okay again we could fill the hour
recapping John fetterman's sad responses
but it's not really that surprising to
anyone who's been following John
fetterman for the past five months you
knew that he was profoundly cognitively
impaired and it turns out he is so you
learn really not that much new about him
what you learn is that everyone around
him from his doctor to his wife to the
media to the Democratic party they're
all liars and they all just got caught
lying the debate went on and on and on
like this during Dr Oz's closing
statement Federal began shouting
uncontrollably about social security
until the moderator hushed him really
look it up
the effect over an hour is to make you
feel very sad for John fetterman this is
humiliating the guy looked exactly like
Billy Bob Thornton in the movie Sling
Blade he really did he couldn't even
read the canned lines his staff was
writing for him
it was pathetic you do wonder about his
wife as he knew about Joe Biden's wife
it seems cruel to do this to a man even
for political power
but again it's the media who covered
John fetterman who should be the most
ashamed they've known the truth for
months
with only one exception that would be
NBC reporter Dasha burns the media lied
to voters about it we don't know
anything about dashu Burns but she at
least tried to be sort of honest here's
what she said after meeting John
fetterman
you'll hear he also still has some uh
problems some challenges with speech and
I'll say Katie that just in some of the
small talk prior to uh the interview
before the closed captioning was up and
running it did seem that he had a hard
time understanding our our conversations
oh that's not allowed so here you have a
young reporter who clear doesn't know
the rules no matter what you actually
see or experience or report
you can't reveal anything that might
hurt the fortunes of the democratic
party that might slow down the team
so clearly Dasher Burns hadn't gotten
that memo and for daring to say that for
honestly reporting what she saw
liberals tried to destroy her Rebecca
traced her again of New York Magazine
said fetterman quote is not at all
impaired he understands everything Molly
Zhang fast said she spoke to fetterman
and quote he understood everything I was
saying and he was funny
podcast hosts Kara Swisher this is like
the this is like the worst people on
social media wrote this on Twitter quote
sorry to say but I talked to John
fetterman for over an hour without stop
or any AIDS and this is just nonsense
maybe this reporter is just bad at Small
Talk blame the girl will ya Kara Swisher
of course
and then Charlotte altar of Time
Magazine whatever that is
also interviewed fetterman recently she
knew perfectly about using capacity they
all did
but Charlotte alter decided to cover for
John fetterman because supporting the
Democratic party is of course her job in
the hours before the debate Charlotte
altered did the bidding the direct
bidding of the fetterman campaign by
trying to lower expectations that was
their goal and she worked on their
behalf quote fetterman has never been a
good debater Ultra added quote everyone
will be watching for fetterman stroke
symptoms I can tell you already what
they are he sometimes says the slightly
wrong word or conjugate something the
wrong way
okay
they're not embarrassed they're caught
working for a Democratic Senate campaign
and they just shrug it off and keep
going they never slow down
so once fetterman got on stage there was
really kind of no lying about it he
humiliated himself the usual chorus
piped up not to admit that they were
wrong but to say yeah he's demented but
it doesn't matter doesn't matter that
he's totally incapable of thinking or
speaking why because abortion abortion
is more important than anything because
it's not a child's sacrifice cult at all
no it's not don't worry
in response to a post stating the
obvious that fetterman is totally
impaired a lawyer at the Democratic
party's main firm Perkins Coy sent this
stalinist tweet quote his ability to
protect a woman's right to choose is not
in doubt this is a harmful tweet delete
it
delete it
of course it's too important to note the
obvious
Senate Democrats tweeted effectively the
same message after the debate quote
Mehmet Oz is a grave threat to a woman's
right to choose John Federer will fight
to protect abortion access Nationwide
that's their response to a guy who is
literally incapable of talking
so what do we learn from this we learn a
couple of things most obviously it tells
us that abortion is more important than
anything else abortion is what really
matters to the left
and if you doubt that consider the case
of 89 year old Dianne Feinstein supports
supposedly represents the country's
biggest state in the U.S Senate
at this point everyone in Washington
knows Dianne Feinstein isn't
representing anyone she's no longer
capable of recognizing old friends and
in April the San Francisco Chronicle to
its credit ran a story in which former
staffers not political enemies but
registered Democrats who voluntarily
worked for Dianne Feinstein in which
these people her friends described
Dianne Feinstein's mental Decline and
said that she was too senile to serve in
the Senate
so in response to that Nancy Pelosi
dismissed their first-hand accounts as
quote unconscionable and ridiculous not
just wrong but immoral
in other words shut up Dianne Feinstein
is on our team and that's all that
matters
to emphasize that point yesterday Kamala
Harris went on a tirade not about
inflation or housing prices or fentanyl
deaths of the Border or the looming
nuclear with Russia but about the thing
that matters most to her and all of them
which is abortion watch this
laws that are being proposed that would
punish women
who dare to exercise self-determination
and make decisions about what they know
to be in their best self-interest
because apparently there are some I call
them extremist so-called leaders
who have decided they're in a better
position than she is to make decisions
about what's in her best interest how
dare they I think that we need to take
back the flag on this issue
this is about freedom and liberty
oh it's about freedom of Liberty this is
the childless middle-aged lady who
forced women across the country out of
their jobs because they wouldn't take
the vaccine that she was pushing on them
suddenly it's their body their choice
again right Barack Obama cut an ad for
John federburst a few days ago he's not
ashamed to do that his argument of
course abortion again watch
in Pennsylvania you've got some
important choices to make this year
including who represents you in the U.S
Senate that's why I'm asking you to vote
for John fetterman this election day
November 8th so when the fate of our
democracy and a woman's right to choose
are on the line
I know John will fight for
pennsylvanians you can count on John
fetterman make sure he can count on you
so it all goes back to that one issue it
always does why is that we're not
exactly sure but it's
hard not to notice that it does
but there's something bigger going on
here fetterman's candidacy like Joe
Biden's candidacy two years ago tells us
something pretty dark about the
Democratic Party
what it tells us is the Democratic party
has such contempt for voters and for
democracy itself and so much confidence
in its ownership of the media end of big
Tech that it no longer has to try to win
your votes Democrats can run Raphael
Warnock an aggressively anti-christian
fake Christian Pastor whose wife
detailed abuse allegations against him
on camera
and that's okay it's still good enough
for a senate seat in Georgia because the
machine keeps working it's not about the
person it's about the party it's not
about the individual it's about the
group
and to prove it they can even run
mentally defective candidates you can
barely speak and only expect them to win
but expect you to accept the outcome no
matter how transparently absurd it is
on November 9th they'll be telling you
that John fetterman got 81 million votes
in Pennsylvania and they'll threaten to
put you in jail if you don't believe it
why wouldn't they do that it worked with
Joe Biden subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight